>> Bret: FINALLY TONIGHT,
THIS WEEK'S NOTABLE
QUOTABLES.
>> MANY IN LEGACY MEDIA LOVE
MASS SHOOTINGS.
CRYING WHITE MOTHERS ARE
RATINGS GOLD.
>> A GUN-FREE ZONE IS LET'S
GO IN AND LET'S ATTACK
BECAUSE BULLETS AREN'T
COMING BACK AT US.
>> I DECIDED TO SUSPEND
SCOTT PETERSON.
>> WHAT SHOULD HE HAVE DONE?
>> WENT, IN ADDRESSED THE
KILLER.
KILLED THE KILLER.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY I
COULD STILL GO IN A STORE
AND BUY A WEAPON OF WAR.
>> COPY CATS ARE COMMON.
WE ARE GOING TO TEACH THE
TEACHERS.
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE THEM A
CONCEAL CARRY PERMIT WHEN
THEY ARE DONE.
>> WE DON'T HAVE TO WONDER
WHY THE PARTY OF NANCY
PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER WON
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
>> THIS IS A BLATANT POWER
GRAB BY THE SUPREME COURT
THAT SEEMS HELL BENT ON --
>> -- HE HAS BEEN TOUGHER ON
RUSSIA IN THE FIRST YEAR
THAN OBAMA WAS IN EIGHT
YEARS COMBINED.
>> THEY WERE DOING BUSINESS
OVERSEAS WITH A NUMBER OF
WHAT WE CALL BAD HOMBRES,
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH.
THIS HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> I TRY LIKE HELL TO HIDE
THAT BALD SPOT, FOLKS.
I WORK HARD AT IT.
>> I'M A BELIEVER IN JESUS
CHRIST AND I'M LOOKING